>>Male Presenter: Great.
I'm very happy to introduce Tomas Sedlacek,
the author of The Economics of Good and Evil.
He
teaches at Charles University and is a member
of the
National Economic Council in Prague.
He's worked as an
advisor to Václav Havel.
He's going to take us on a
whirlwind tour of intellectual history, from
the epic of
Gilgamesh to the Hebrew Bible, to Greek philosophers,
the New Testament, the medieval period, Mandeville,
Hume,
Adam Smith, Marx, points at the many stories
in
economics that don't show up in the formulas,
but still
resonate in people's lives.
We've over-mathematized, and
so missed important philosophical issues that
are
hidden in the formulas that would rather be
precisely
wrong than roughly correct, or which mistake
beauty for
truth in Krugman's phrase.
It's time to remember the
alternative stories to get us out of the mess
we're in.
It's time to realize that invisible hands
and
equilibrium are every bit as much myths as
unicorns and
dragons.
They may be useful for a story, but they need
to be taken with a big grain of salt.
Please join me in
welcoming Tomas Sedlacek.
[Clapping]
>>TOMAS: So thank you.
It's a great pleasure
to be here with you today and let's really
do this quite
quickly, and let's try and see how far we
can go down
the history of Economics of Good and Evil.
Okay.
So
one of my basic points is that we've never
separated the
two.
It was always economics and morality being
connected really together, not -- well, with
Adam Smith
being sort of a climax of the debate; Adam
Smith did not
really start this whole notion of economics,
but Adam
Smith was a moral philosopher, and so was
Hume, and so
were actually all the classical philosopher
-- I mean
economists were basically philosophers.
Now, what I
think is one of the struggle and the trouble
we have today
in 2011 is that we view these two words absolutely
separate.
We have this impersonal, technical,
math-looking ideology of the free market that
simply
runs like an engine, like a robot, and is
value free,
allegedly, is absolutely inhuman, it's just
like a
machine.
And that's why we treat it with calculus,
that's how we treat it with all sorts of mechanistic
approaches, as if it was a computer program,
as if it
was a stimulation of work.
And that strange body,
zombie, that does not really have a soul -- we
made it
to look like it doesn't have a soul -- produces
results
that we don't really like.
And of course if you look
down on the best selling books on Amazon or
at any
bookstore, it would all be books that are
critical on
economy.
Where did we go wrong, the animal spirits,
the
myths of the rational market, you can go on.
You can
actually go through all the books that you
see on the
best selling list and you will not find one
that goes
praising the economy for whatever good that
we have
around us.
So it is disjointed, it creates results that
we're not happy with.
On the other hand, we have moral
expectations that the market is going to solve
everything, it's going to make everybody happy,
and
everybody better off.
So the problem was or is what we
had together is now disjointed.
So you know in the book
of Job in the Old Testament it says "Should
I only
accept from the hand of the Lord the good
things and not
the bad things?" and I think we have a similar
--
similar guiding narrative when it comes to
this myth of
the market is supposed to do everything right.
So the
markets in a way are either hated and they
are the cause
of all problems as we have quotes in the New
Testament
and other spiritual sources that there is
a huge divide
between money, and money is the root of all
evil --
which is a misquote by the way, but never
mind and then
we have this spiritual, soft, human, wishy
washy zone of
life, and this one is supposed to correct
the doings of
this machine called the market.
So in practical
application you have the government, which
is supposed
to, the story goes, soften the results of
the market,
but these two are disjointed, they're not
together
anymore, and that's where kind of the problem
comes
from.
Now, the remedy is not in correcting the -- so
okay.
Let's go into mythology.
If you look on all
myths that we have around us or if you look
at horror
stories, there are basically two things that
we fear.
We fear when the body and soul gets disjointed.
All
right?
So if you get the body disjointed from the
soul,
you get zombies on the one hand, or you get
ghosts and
spirits on the other.
The thing doesn't work very well
if it's -- if it's disjointed.
Also mark that if you go
and analyze all the myths and -- including
modern myths,
we fear two things.
When a human being is mixed with an
animal, vampire, werewolf, all sorts of wizards
that
live in the forest and they have animal-like
behavior on
the one hand; and then there's another guarding
fear,
really, that we have, and that is that of
robots.
You
see that in Matrix, you see that in the War
of the
Worlds.
So, how to read this.
I think this is exactly
the same area.
We've disjointed something that should
have been together, body and soul.
You disjoint that,
you get horror figures that we are afraid
of, tremendous
fear out of these things.
They look like human beings,
zombies for example, but they act like animals.
They
eat, I mean, the common narrative of all zombie
stories
is this used to be my wife; or my friend;
or my father;
suddenly he, or she, or it ceases to be human,
it
becomes an animal, and it attacks you, and
it treats you
as if you were just a piece of meat.
And the other
problem is that of human beings becoming machine-like.
So how do we read this economically?
I think the moment
you start disjoining these two, you get into
a
catastrophe situation, which is the place
of a human
being is always to be together.
A rational,
mathematical way of thinking needs to be part
of human,
but it mustn't be only that.
These are all the
Hitler-like characters.
You saw quite nicely in the
last movie, for example, Avatar, you have
this soldier
who only wants profit, who calculates who
doesn't care
for who he kills while he does that.
So that's a true
horror figure.
And, on the other hand, you have these
animalistic -- animal spirit tendencies.
So as an
economist, you can see one extreme being homoeconomicus,
rational, calculating, mathematical, cold,
calculus of
consumption and production, nothing else matters.
And
on the other hand animal spirits, which is
a concept
that John Maynard Keynes talked about in his
general theory,
something that we economists fear but we don't
understand.
It's a singularity.
It's an animal that
reacts, that propels us forward, that's adventurous,
but
it's not controlled by reason.
So you can see this fear
when you disjoin two things that should be
together, and
I argue that this is exactly what happened
with the
economy.
We got ridiculous results with the market
that
nobody really likes, often, and we have ridiculous
expectations that really can't be matched
by anybody
else except for maybe God or maybe a host
of gods;
definitely not the market.
So that's one way of looking
at it.
Let me take another fly through -- fly through
the history of economy, and maybe because
I am speaking
in the premises of Google, maybe answer the
question why
Plato would love Google.
Okay.
So if we actually go
fast forward the history of the economy, you
will learn
that it was -- in the beginning it was important
to
actually master material things such as acts,
and be
close to sources of iron, or maybe salt, or
be at the
cross roads of a passage that people had to
pass
through, or information you had to pass through,
or --
but more likely material things that you had
to pass
through.
That was the time of matter, where matter
mattered the most.
Then we had the time of
manufacturing where it wasn't all that important
where
that thing -- there we go.
Advertisements are falling
apart.
What kind of a world are we living in?
Founding
superstructure.
Manufacturing, it wasn't really
important where you got the stuff from, but
the nations
that owned companies -- I mean, owned manufacturing
infrastruc- -- I mean, yeah, manufacturers,
that's where
Ford's T-time.
. These nations were the rich nations.
We move from that from a -- from things, from
things to
thinks, where thinking was important.
This was the time
of lawyers, this was the time of accountants,
this was
the time of advisors.
And eventually we are moving into
the area, I argue, of non-things where -- and
I think this
is the time where we actually witness is thinking,
planning, doing things rigorously is no longer
important.
What's important is the soft skills and
moving into further level of abstractness.
Let me give
an example of three titans -- let me get rid
of this --
of three titans of the past.
One was actually IBM which
you know you could actually knock on the product
of IBM
and you had to ship it, and you owned a piece
of matter.
If you tried really hard you could turn it
into an ax or
something else; it was matter.
Second generation was
Microsoft.
Now, the product of Microsoft is extremely
abstract; you can't really knock on it, but
at least you
can put it in a box and you can sell it, and
you can
come home and you can say to your family,
"Look, I
bought a new product by Microsoft" for example.
Okay,
and third in this legion of titans is Google,
where you
can't really box Google.
That's absolutely absurd
thought.
You can't actually buy anything from Google,
and the wonderful trick is while Microsoft
is trying to
employ people and pay them for doing things
for it,
Google does it exactly the other way around.
It employs
people voluntarily.
So you guys have millions of
employees uploading things to YouTube, putting
things on
also Wikipedia is running down the same logic,
where you
absolutely conquered the whole idea of matter.
What's
wonderful is the thing that you can't look
for in
Google -- once I had high fever and I was
at home and I
was looking for a particular book, a physical
book,
okay.
That was in the times that books were actually
printed in paper.
And I was looking through my study
and I couldn't find the book, and as I was
in my high
fevers I thought okay, well, I'll just Google
it.
Google -- the trick of Google is it will not
find
anything real.
All the things that you deal with is
information, and of course it has a value
of its own,
but it's not real, it's not really anything
that you can
knock on or you can actually situate or localize.
And
this is why I think the original idea of the
mind
conquering the matter kind of materializes
in our
generation in the development of Google where
you
actually create sort of a rule, an upload
space such as
YouTube or the Internet, and then you live
as the gate
to this enumerable chaos.
That I think is something
where we will go forward.
One last thought and then
I'll be ready to take your questions in this.
Nietzsche
wrote about the age of a child.
He says, "In the
development of a human being, we have three
ages.
One
age is the age of a camel.
Now, a camel takes upon
himself heavy burdens and wants to travel
or travels
through dry deserts without water and is actually
enslaved for a purpose of somebody else.
Then you have
an age of a lion.
Lion fights, and rebels, and attacks
everything in the surrounding, and it is impossible
to
saddle him and impossible to tell him to walk
on and
serve somebody else.
It doesn't lend towards it.
And
the third age is the age of the child.
The child is
playful, the child doesn't t really worry
about
anything, the child wants to be educated,
the child
wants to learn, the child wants to stand in
awe.
Now, I
think this is one other way how we could actually
read -- and Nietzsche had this under personal
development,
but it's easy to see how we can apply this
into the
development of our day and age where the whole
thing
with iPod, for example, is the advantage of
an iPod is
that it's fun.
A small child can operate it and it is
not serious, it is not meant to be serious,
and this is
what's beautiful about [pause] this is what's
beautiful
about Google.
It is -- for many people it's the gateway
into the chaos of Internet, but the page itself
is
empty.
It's a white page, which we just saw, and
the
only thing you have there is a line where
you, yourself,
type the way you like it.
And this is something, a direction, into
which we are moving.
Who would have thought 20 years
ago that you can make any money on searching
in the
Internet?
You're not even providing Internet access,
you're not providing Internet space, you're
not
computers, you're not providing anything except
for
searching.
And the searching also we can look at it
from a completely opposite view.
We think that we're
searching information where, in fact, we are
searching
the 'not'.
Because what Google does, it filters out all
the things that you don't want to know.
There was a
medieval monk, Meister Eckhart -- you've probably
heard
of him -- and when he was asked what will
burn us in
hell, he said, "In hell, it will be the not,
the
negative that is burning."
In other words, my hand will
burn from coal only because my hand is not
coal.
So
everything in my hand that is not coal, burns.
If my
hand was made of coal, then you could torture
me as you
want, but it would not hurt me because it
is the not.
It is the difference, it is the gap between
these two
elements that is burning.
Similar, Google actually
filters out the 'not' more than it actually
looks for the
things that you want to do.
So the economy is
becoming -- and this is I think one way to
contemplate
about where the future is developing, and
it's
developing from things through thinks, rationality,
to
non-thinks, to personalization, to emotional
enjoyment,
to playfulness, and these, I think, will be
the products
in the future that will gain the attention
of customers.
And surprisingly this emancipation of economy
from
matter to pure mind jumping over the rational
period is
something that we're witnessing today.
In my book, I
touch upon subjects such as these.
I start with the
epic of Gilgamesh only to show that there
is a lot of
economic thinking in ancient myth.
You can go down any
basic three founding cultures that we have
in Europe and
America, which is the Old Testament, the Greeks,
Christianity, and the Sumerian mythology,
which was a
founding inspiration for a lot of the Greeks
and a lot
of the Hebrews.
So the first half of the book talks
about economics and mythology, and the second
half talks
about mythology in modern economics.
What do we believe
today as economists?
And let me just give you one
example of an ancient story which explains
current
situation maybe better than all these models
that we
have.
It's -- [INAUDIBLE] -- I don't know if you...
we
now are witnessing what we call a business
cycle.
It's
the most recent business cycle.
So it's always useful
to ask for the oldest ever business cycle.
Anything
comes to your mind?
The oldest business cycle in
recorded history of mankind.
>>Male #1: [INAUDIBLE]
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
But a business cycle proper.
>>Male #1 [INAUDIBLE]
TOMAS: There you go.
This is in the old
testament where Pharaoh has a dream, and he
dreams about
seven fat deers -- seven fat cows, if you
recall, and
seven thin cows.
That is the oldest business cycle
proper.
Here's grain, GDP as we probably say today.
We have
seven years of surplus, and seven years of
famine.
Now,
Pharaoh immediately asks Joseph okay, what
am I to do
with this?
This is obviously a situation, and how do
I
deal with it?
And Joseph, because he read Keynes a lot
when he was younger, gives him an answer.
Well, in the
good years, do not eat everything that grows.
Save your
energy and build silos -- I mean, store houses.
So it's
a form of consumer energy that you don't use.
In other
words, you could be on this level of joy -- or
consumption, but do not eat it all.
Decrease your
consumption here so that in the bad years
you can
increase your consumption from, I don't know
-X to a
level which you can survive at.
This level of
consumption we were all dying; this level
of consumption
we can survive.
So what's the lesson to take from this
story?
First of all, the role of economist never
was
increase of GDP growth.
It was only in the times of
crises when we are to increase GDP growth
from let's say
-20 to -7.
Incidentally, by the way, in the year 2008,
if we had balanced budget -- if you guys in
America had
a balanced budget, your GDP would be -23 percent.
Now,
the number itself isn't important.
What's important is
that nobody asks this question.
So we consider whatever
growth, no matter how much debt-induced it
is, to be a
true, healthy, natural level of growth.
But in fact
we're just dealing with energy.
Energy and money travel
in time.
So this is, of course fiscal policy, you store
the energy, you run fiscal surpluses.
That means you slow
down the economy, which is the role of the
economist.
The role of the economist is decreasing the
amplitude of
a business cycle, never, never in the long
run to
increase GDP -- GDP growth, definitely not
by fiscal
stimuli.
And here you have fiscal deficits.
Okay.
So
what did we do to bring it to some sort of
a catharsis?
We also -- by the way, from the year 2001
with we had
the September 11 attacks, we had seven very
good years
that were bracketed by two very significant
events.
This was one not only geopolitically, but
this was the
year when America produced its last budget
surplus, this
is the year when Fed started the policy of
extremely low
interest rates, etc., etc.
And the hike of the crises
was collapse of Lehman Brothers, which was
by the way,
2008, September 15th.
So of course I think this is just
a pure coincidence, but you see seven very
good years
bracketed by two significant events.
Now, the question
is, what did we do with our fiscal policy
here?
We did
exactly the opposite.
Either we didn't do anything,
some countries just stayed on the level of
debt that
they had before, but many countries, including
United
States, increased and was not running fiscal
surpluses,
but was running fiscal deficits, in other
words,
increasing GDP growth during good years.
So not only did
we not save in the in the store houses, but
that
imaginary storehouse was full of IOUs.
So we took the
energy -- and this is why there is such a
huge, huge
divide here, and this is why the crisis is
much deeper
than it should -- than it had to be, because
we wasted
that energy boost during good years when we
didn't need
to do that at all and now when we want to
boost the
economies, we are running into bankruptcies,
not only in
Europe, but also here.
So what's my point here?
My
point here now is that we had similar situations,
similar stories, back in the history 4,000,
3,000 years
ago.
People were aware of it and they treated it
--
instead of mathematical, apparently they treated
it with
stories that a seven-year-old child could
understand.
What's even more striking is that we -- well,
you could
go as far as to say that we were blinded by
all the
self-assuring mathematical models telling
us basically
this, that we didn't -- it didn't -- Well,
the wisdom of
this story, again, that a seven-year-old child
understands is something that we trespassed
against and
we couldn't be wise enough to act at least
the way
Pharaoh acted in the time where, you know,
economic
studies were primitive.
So there's still a lot of
things that we can learn from this.
I think this is
exactly the rule that we should adopt also
in our
thinking.
That means in good years target some level
of
growth.
Let's say we could have grown by 6 percent,
but
we will only grow by 2, and this energy we
will
recuperate so to speak so that we can use
it in the
times of the crises.
Yeah.
I'll end here.
Instead of
giving you an overview of the book, I think
it's better
that I gave you these three stories that I
think are
sort of explaining or guarding the development
of our
economic thought.
The first story was animal and human,
and we -- and robot, sorry, and we human beings
have to
be in the middle.
There will never be psychological
beasts.
You will always have these two tendencies,
and
also the economy, homoeconomicus and animal
spirits as
to inborn tendencies or market and ethics.
We, if you
separate them, it becomes a horror.
So that was the
first story.
The second story from the book is the
economy going more and more abstract, more
and more
playful, and less and less serious.
And the third story
is the behavior of age and Asians when it
came to
business cycles and a comparison of how we
foolishly
from this point of view behave today.
So thank you for
your attention, and let's move into the debate,
please.
Okay.
>>Male #2: So you showed us that Keynes is
right.
>>TOMAS: Do we need a microphone?
Probably.
>>Male #2: Okay.
So the intriguing thing here is
you've shown us that Keynes, was right, at
least within
the context of the particular story that you
told.
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
>>Male #2: And that there definitely is a
role for
fiscal policy and it's a role -- I think and
the
important thing that you said is that we need
to
understand you don't do fiscal policy, fiscal
stimulus
all the time.
>>TOMAS: Right.
>>Male #2: Only when it's --
Exactly.
>>Male #2: -- When it's necessary.
>>TOMAS: Right.
>>Male #2: But this other side of the world,
you
know, the Friedman and company, the monetarists
. Do the
monetarists appear at all in the Bible?
What is their
role in the world --
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
>>Male #2: -- as opposed to the fiscal?
TOMAS: Those are very good questions.
So you
know if somebody asks me about Keynes I say
okay, yes I
am Keynesian but we are all Keynesians.
This is what
Friedman says.
We are all Keynesians now.
I think once
you go further we are left of Keynes.
In other words,
if we were to apply Keynesian policies, we
would have to
be right wing and more conservative.
So let's first go
to Keynes and see if we can be actually -- because
okay
here.
What is a more conservative value?
Higher GDP
growth or balanced budget?
Because here you have a
choice.
You can either be growing towards balanced
budget, or you can be stimulating your GDP.
What is
more conservative, and what is more populist
, and what is more leftist and what is trying
to please all?
I
think higher GDP.
That's -- everybody can do.
That is
populist.
And we have a -- because we have right-wing
populism which means decreasing taxes when
you can't afford
to do so at the expense of deficits, and we
have leftist
populism, otherwise increasing expenditure
which you
can't afford to do so, at the expense of government
--
of deficit.
So this is a Keynesian bastard, what we're
doing today.
Our economic policy I describe as a
Keynesian bastard because half of it government
can run
deficits, we took, can we multiplied it by
two, which
you know will not get you to the original
hole.
So
that's why I think Keynes got some negative
press is
that he was accused of allowing budget deficits,
yes,
under conditions that you can run budget surpluses.
So
we really took half of Keynes and bastardized
him with
sweet-tooth political populism.
So that's just the
comment on Keynes.
Now, going to fiscal policy, you
could re-tell the story in fiscal policy as
well, and
instead of fiscal surpluses you would have
cheap --
cheap money.
Did I say fiscal?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
You
can re-tell -- I'm more of a fiscal macro-economist,
but
you can re-tell the whole story in monetary
policy,
sorry, saying here you should have high interest
rates
slowing down the economy, here you should
have low
interest rates.
And again the story is the same.
What
is the problem that got us into the -- not
the only
thing--, but what is the popular understanding
about what
got us into crises?
Over consumption.
How are we going
to get out of it?
By consuming even more.
And, you
know, Obama gets blamed by many economists,
oh, you're
not inducing the economy to spend, and this
is the
debate that we have in Europe as well.
We have to run
fiscal deficits to get everything moving.
So we will
spend our way out of the crisis.
And the same story in
terms of monetary policy.
What got us into trouble?
If
you open FT or Wall Street Journal, cheap
money.
Too
much cheap money, too low interest rate.
What's the
solution to that problem?
Even more cheap money and
even lower interest rates.
This does not work, and my
problem -- and this is I think this is getting
to the
core of the issue and I thank you here.
Will we go
bankrupt?
Will we not go bankrupt?
I don't care.
Here
I think I'm a Keynesian.
I don't care how much deficit
you run here.
It is okay to run a deficit in crises,
and it is okay to run low interest rate monetary
policy
in crises.
But what we don't have as a part of the
story is a firm commitment that we will not
get drunk on
a Friday evening.
And while are we talking about
drinking, there's another parable I have when
it comes
to monetary policy.
[sounds of paper flipping] Let's stay here.
Energy can travel
in time in terms of fiscal policy.
We do that by
surplus, because surplus is our first fiscal
deficits.
Now, we know -- this is Economics 101 -- that
the
government has basically two ways to steer
-- not really
guide, but steer the economy.
One is fiscal policy, and
the other one is monetary policy.
Here you manipulate
with debt, and here you manipulate with money.
So --
and I simplify here, and I do that willingly
because we
only have a little time -- monetary policy
is the
monopoly, the right of the government to print
money,
simply put.
Fiscal policy is again a monopoly of the
government to print debt.
You -- I cannot make you
indebted.
I cannot come see you and say, okay.
This is
what politicians do.
They give you a gift which you
have to pay for yourself.
This is -- whoops [cell phone rings].
I thought
I had it switched off.
So here -- So printing money,
printing debt.
We, as mankind, have realized that it is
not healthy when a politician has the right
to print
money.
So what we did is we took that right away
and we
gave it to a Fed central bank.
In the case of Europe and
America, we have a central bank or European
Central Bank
so Italians can no longer print money; Californians
can
not print money because they're in default.
So always
in the past, take Californian situation, or
Greek
situation, or any other situation, we are
in problem; we
will just print money; we'll inflate our way
out of
this.
This was a temptation too large for any
politicians to carry.
So that ring of power, so to
speak, had to be destroyed.
While we're talking about
the ring of power, why did Aragorn, why did
Gandalf, why
did Galadriel never touch the ring?
Too much power.
It
was a temptation that all of the wise in this
trilogy
knew it's too much of a temptation.
So the conclusion
was, we will not use the ring, albeit it is
extremely
powerful and we could use it against Sauron
and Saruman
themselves.
This was Boromir's mistake.
That's why he
died.
The ring of power must be destroyed because
the
ring of power exits one characteristic is
called by
psychologists "objet petit a", which is something
that
is created to serve, you end up serving it.
This is the
basic plot in Matrix.
We've created robots, computers,
machines to serve us, blah, blah, blah; at
the end of
the narrative, we serve them.
This is what Kundera, if
you read Kundera, writes about.
A male starts usually a
sexual game with a female thinking that he
can control
it.
At the end of the day, the game sort of has
a will
of its own and it controls.
So from a puppeteer, you
become a puppet.
And you can -- and 10,000 stories are
like this.
And it also, by the way, goes nicely for
debt.
Why do you take a debt?
It's something that I
can control.
I need a new computer, I need a new car, I
need a new investment.
I take debt, I think I can
manage it, blah, blah, blah.
At the end of the day, you
are a slave to that debt.
By the way, in all New
Testament languages: Greek, Aramaic, and even
Latin,
the word "debt" and "sin" are synonyms; you
have it in
modern Germany -- in modern German to this
very day.
Okay.
So I would argue here that what we need to
do is
we also -- what's the difference between printing
money
and printing debt?
At the end of the day, the
difference is not that large.
Why should politicians be
standing up against the temptation to print
debt?
If
we -- let's imagine how the crises would look
like if we
had fiscal -- monetary policy.
If politicians had
monetary policy at their disposal what would
be the
result?
Tremendous inflation.
Ridiculous levels of
inflation.
We can't do that.
This hand is bound behind
our backs.
So what do we revert to?
Debt.
The sin
of monetary policy is hyperinflation, the
sin of
fiscal policy is debt.
This is why we don't have a
problem with inflation, by the way.
This is why we have
problem with debt.
Let me finish this answer by giving
a similar analogy to in what way is alcohol
similar to
interest rate? [paper rustling] What makes
money time travel possible is
interest rate.
We live in a society where you earn
money like this.
This is your retirement age, this is
where you become a CEO and CFO, be you you
need money
like this.
When you establish a family you need a new
car, you need a new house, you need blah,
blah, blah
children and everything.
So, how to solve this
conundrum?
Interest rate.
So we live in buildings that
are -- in houses that are not ours, it's called
leasing -- mortgage; we drive cars that are
not ours; we
watch screens that are not ours.
This is fine as long
as these two hills meet.
If this hill is smaller, you
break a leg, you have a crisis, the oil prices
go up or
the future expectations of your future do
not match,
we're in a problem.
This is another way to read the
crises is this happened.
Fine.
So it is really
interest rate that allows money time travel.
When I
take on a loan, let's say I borrow $10,000,
it looks
like I'm getting it from a bank or from a
friend, but
really what's happening is I'm tunneling that
from my
own future because there will come a time
when I will
need to pay back, and that's where my consumer
energy
will decrease.
I will have to either work hard or
consume less at my current expense.
So I cannot vacuum
clean and laser point that energy from the
past which I
think I will not need into the future -- from
the future
to current present when I think I need it
more than I
need it in the past.
Now, alcohol does the same thing
like interest rate.
How exactly?
Friday evening you
are occasionally dancing in the bar 'til three
in the
morning having all that energy and you're
being very
witty, and you talk to people you would never
have the
guts to talk to and these girls are -- which
is most
surprising -- they talk back to you, and where's
all
this energy coming from?
We think it's the alcohol,
that it's giving us the energy.
That is not correct.
The only thing alcohol does, it time travels
energy over
short distances of time, namely, Saturday
morning.
So -- but the energy of the weekend is constant.
But
alcohol allows energy time travel one direction
only.
You can't save up your mood by not drinking
over short
distances of time.
Interest rate, on the contrary --
and by the way, interest rate is something
that all
ancients starting with Aristotle, which I
deal with in
the book, Aristotle, Holy Koran, the Old Testament,
Vedas , anywhere you look, all the ancient
-- the wise
wizards or founders of our culture and society
warned us
against interest rate.
They said don't use it.
If you
don't have to, don't use it.
You will remember all
these rules all the way until Thomas Aquinas,
interest
rate was banned.
It was one of the worst sins that you
could do in the medieval period.
There was a special
place in hell reserved for usurers.
What have we done?
We have done -- we have made interest rate
a founding
pillar of our society.
Our society's unimaginable
without the interest rate.
Now, the ancients knew
exactly why interest rate is bad.
If you read it
Aristotle, his argumentation is very weak.
He acknowledges
it.
And here's why, I think, and that's in the
analogy
with alcohol.
It's fine to get drunk on a Friday
evening if you know you have Saturday morning
awaiting
for you; it is not clever to get drunk on
Sunday evening
when you have something important to do on
a Monday
evening, such as go to work maybe, or have
an interview,
or travel a long distance.
Now, the trick difference
between these two here is that we can, with
reasonable
probability, see one day ahead in the future.
You
cannot see 40 years ahead, and this is yet
another way
how to read the crises.
We have landed with our
hangover into a period where we cannot afford
one.
The
growth is slowing, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
So
that's why maybe we should be very cautious
about the
redistributing time and money, money, energy.
So that's
the monetary policy story.
>>Male #3: If I could, just one more.
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
>>Male #3: The story as you tell it, especially
with
the business cycle before, obviously you have
to -- you
know, build up a surplus during the good times
and then
you spend it during the bad times, etc., because
you're
trying to basically cut out the variability
in the
system, etc..
But it's a profoundly simple story.
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
>>Male #3: It is attacked every day and declared
to
be wrong.
There are -- there are millions of people
out
there, leaders of our country, unfortunately
appearing
to be the majority of the movement, who attack
this and
say it is absolute idiocy, it is lunacy, it
is wrong, it
is evil, it is bad.
Why?
What's wrong with the story?
It's simple, it's compelling for me, but apparently
it
isn't for others.
What's wrong with this story?
>>TOMAS: I think it's more what's wrong with
our perception of what we deserve today.
We believe we
deserve -- and this is I think we believe
we deserve
this.
We could have -- it was -- okay.
I'm going to be
simplifying here.
The economy grew at 6 percent.
We could
have afforded a house this size.
We could have gone
down, and we should have, to prepare for the
winter in the
summer.
Not only were we not content with what we
had,
but we wanted more and this is the role of
politicians.
If they can manipulate money supply or debt,
why not
promise more when you can?
Nobody will give you what I
can promise you.
I think this is the key story of
politicians.
This is why I think we need to for the sake
of
politicians, get rid of this temptation by
confiscating
monetary policy -- fiscal policy the same
way we have
confiscated fiscal policy two generations
ago, by
creating -- it's okay.
You can go many different
directions and either way you like it, either
there'll
be -- and there is a lot of talk about that
among the
economists, so-called fiscal council, which
-- or on the
level of Europe and on the level of any federation
such
as the United States, a conglomerate of, say,
minister of
finance or treasurers will agree according
to a formula,
this is something that I have suggested with
the
National Economic Council for the Czech government,
something that I think it would be workable
for European
Union as well, especially after the Greek
experience.
Have a rule, a fiscal rule such as GDP growth
plus
deficit should be smaller or equal to four,
or constant,
depends on the economy.
In other words, target a
4 percent GDP growth.
This is the case of Czech
Republic, I think, a reasonable level of growth
for
developing economies.
For America this would be less,
lets say two.
And if GDP is let's say 6 percent, then
we should create 2 percent budget surpluses
so that this
is Czech Republic, let's say Greece is going
-7, then
they can go into 11 percent budget deficits.
This is a
rule that allows you to use the power of fiscal
policy
in the bad years, 11 percent budget deficit
is huge
that will help in the crises.
But, it also forces
you -- this is the only rule that forces you
into fiscal
surpluses during good years.
And I think this
autopilot -- we already have this autopilot
in monetary
policy, by the way, Milton Friedman invented
it, and that
is, money supply should mimic the development
of GDP.
And also deficit should go against -- should
be
anti-cyclical , so to speak, of growth.
So when it grows,
yeah.
I've already explained that.
So that's another
way how to just you know get the discretion
out of it.
And of course it will be still question for
politicians
who to tax.
Do I tax the poor?
Do I tax the rich?
Do
I tax the successful?
Do I tax the unsuccessful?
This
is a political debate and it must remain a
political
debate.
And the other question is, who do I give the
money to?
Do I support the poor or do I support the
rich?
Do I support the successful, or do I support
the
unsuccessful?
Do I support the strong, or do I support
the weak?
Those are good questions.
They're not easily
answered and they should remain political.
What
shouldn't happen in the meantime is that politicians
get
to print.
I tax little, I give out a lot.
How can I do
this trick?
Well, this is called debt.
This -- so you
collect money and you print 20 percent more,
and you
give it out.
This print of 20 percent more should be
confiscated.
>>Male #3: Given that politicians lie, I mean,
the
Greek problem in large part was they had some
rules as
far as what they could do --
>>TOMAS: [soda spraying] Whoa.
>>Male #4: And they had big bang -- they had
big
banks help them --
>>TOMAS: Big bangs, or big banks?
>>Male #4: Big banks --
>>TOMAS: Okay.
>>Male #4: -- help them cheat.
>>TOMAS: Right.
>>Male #4: And politicians will always cheat
if they
can because the -- the last stoic politician
died
probably about 500 years ago.
We all have really stupid
epicureans running the place.
>>TOMAS: Yeah.
>>Male #4: So how do you keep them from lying?
>>TOMAS: Then you shouldn't put your hopes
up
into electing a politician who is honest and
sincere,
and good, and good meaning, and faithful,
and truthful.
Instead, change the system so it doesn't matter
if he or
she is thus.
In other words, if you take this tool away
from them, you can have an idiot who will
not be able to
do harm.
Do you know what I mean?
I have no -- I
have -- so I think all of us suffer Messianic
Complex.
We believe somebody should come and take things
in
control.
Some sort of a messiah, a
politician who is as you describe, honest
and sincere.
Well, he's not coming, or he didn't come for
a long
time, and even Jesus, who was expected to
do this, to be
a political messiah, didn't play that role
intentionally .
He was not a political messiah.
So my answer is,
instead of hoping for better people, let's
just create a
better system where you do not leave that
to a
discretion of people.
You don't allow this propensity.
>>Male #5: What you seem to be going for if
we don't
go with the fiscal council, which would be
hard to do in
this country, one would would hope because
it's pretty
antidemocratic and relies on people of privilege
and
such, but if we go with the formula --
>>TOMAS: We already have that in monetary
policy.
>>Male #5: We do, and there are a lot of people
that
are unhappy about that.
>>TOMAS: But should we give it back to
politicians?
>>Male #5: Okay.
But it sounds like to go with the
formula, whether or not the formula is enforced
by
council or by law, this would be the sort
of thing where
you would write in saying that essentially
the tax rate
is determined by a calculation of a GDP or
some portion
of it?
How do you --
>>Tomas: You can have a Swedish model
here where you have high expenditures and
high taxes.
No problem, as long as you don't do deficits.
>>Male #5: What is the definition of how the
adjustments are made?
>>TOMAS: Same way it's done every year.
Every
year we determine this year we're going to
have that
level of deficit.
And we will -- and yeah, we'll have
to have more anti-cyclical taxes or some sort
of
anti-cyclical expenditures.
>>Male #5: Okay.
So at this point the adjustment of
the anti-cyclical component.
>>TOMAS: Yes.
>>Male #5: Taxes.
So every year you'd have your base
tax then every year there'd be -- or anti-cyclical
tax
and then --
>>TOMAS: For example.
>>Male #5: -- and how it goes up or down,
depending on
how the GDP wants?
>>TOMAS: And the economy actually does that
itself if it is not disturbed by politician.
In good
years, you tend to have higher tax revenues
because
companies collect more taxes, and less unemployed
so you
don't have to give out that many expenditures.
>>Male #5: Are there any actual real-life
countries
that divide their tax into components, the
base, plus
the anti-cyclical, and then do actually adjust
the --
>>TOMAS: You, taxes are that way.
Progressive
taxes are -- in progressive taxation, you
already have
this incorporated.
[pause] The more you make, the more you get
taxed.
That's progressive taxation.
And if your level
of income decreases, you pay lesser not amount,
but
also percentage of taxes.
So you wouldn't have to
change much.
>>Male #5: Okay.
So we already have supposedly
progressive taxes here.
Why doesn't it work for us?
>>TOMAS: The problem is, somebody comes up
--
okay.
Let's have a little situation.
[paper flipping] The economy's
growing and your taxes -- your tax rate -- this
is the
budget.
Your tax revenues are rising and your
expenditures are decreasing.
And if you let that be on
some sort of an autopilot, the budget will
go itself
into surplus during good years.
But, of course, this is
extremely tempting because what does a budget
surplus mean?
Is
it already 10:00 o'clock?
Because this is going to be a
very -- 10:00 o'clock in the evening.
Just a joke.
This is going to be perverse.
Imagine you're running an
economy where you gather -- collect more taxes
than you
give in expenditures.
What is the temptation?
The
temptation of course is if you're right wing,
decrease
taxes immediately, kick the automatic tendency
of an
economy to stabilize itself, kick it in the
-- in the --
where do you kick people here in America?
Kick it in
the right knee.
[chuckles] And the tendency of a left-wing
politician is to increase expenditures immediately.
So
just letting that, you know, resisting the
temptation
like when Odyssey was going in the island
of the sirens, bind
the hands, close the ears, which is, by the
way, what
Fed is doing.
Fed is not supposed to -- or central
banks are not supposed to care for political
cycle.
Whether there's elections or not, we don't
care.
We are
just listening to keeping the monetary supply
-- I mean
keeping the inflation stable.
Low and stable.
So
Finland did this.
They had more tax revenue than they
gave out.
This is why they were able to decrease their
taxes.
Yet, having a level of taxation is huge, close
to 50 percent of GDPs being taxed.
So that is, of
course, that is a political decision of a
nation: Do
you want to be America with low taxes or Finland
with
high taxes and high expenditures?
That's fine, only
don't cheat.
So this is democratic.
I think this is
absolutely democratic.
>>Male presenter: We're out of time, so thank
you very much.
Let's thank him very much.
[Clapping]
>>TOMAS: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
>>TOMAS: So again I apologize for coming late.
It was my secretary wrote instead of the 72
number on
the 93, she wrote seventy-second street in
the
intersection with the nine.
So I was up there -- so I
really apologize.
This time it wasn't my fault.
>>Male presenter: If you'd like to join us
for lunch, that's
fine.
We close at 2:00 o'clock.
If we don't go, we're going to miss lunch.